We have a discussion forum of sorts at on
Reddit at David Pakman dot com slash Reddit.
That's our EDI's DHT. We now have somewhere
around 21000 of our viewers and listeners
subscribed there. And there were three posts
I spotted this morning with similar themes
when it comes to the November election. And
some of this is reassuring. But I also want
to talk about sort of the cautionary aspects
of it. So user the final play down posted.
Only one will be president. I choose Biden
and I am reassured to some degree that a lot
of the very loud voices that four months ago
were saying Biden's not progressive enough.
If it's not Bernie or not Toul C or whoever,
you know, Yang, then I kind of don't care
if it's Trump or Biden or a lot of those voices
I'm not hearing from anymore. And what I am
hearing is, you know, I now understand the
importance of removing Donald Trump and I'm
glad to see that user wagon wheel. What had
a similar post, which was this election, is
pretty simple. A majority of Americans are
suffering and sick and tired of Trump's shtick.
And Biden is a more palatable moderate alternative.
It's very sober, right? It's not. Biden is
the future of the progressive movement. It's
we have to remove Donald Trump. That's the
takeaway. And I'm sort of, to some degree,
reassured by seeing this. And then a third
post will also this one from a wagon wheel.
What is do you think Trump has given up the
announcement about leaving the World Health
Organization? Just seems like a burn at all
to the ground move.
I'm getting more and more messages about that,
which is does Trump even really want to win?
Is Trump trying to torpedo his own reelection?
I think that it's not a dangerous path to
go down, but it's one that if we go too far
down, it could dissuade people from voting.
And listen, Trump, what we know about Trump
is that he's an extreme narcissist with significant
delusions of grandeur. And I don't believe
that in any conscious way Donald Trump is
going to throw in the towel or not try to
win. What I do believe will happen is if Trump
loses, he's gonna do what narcissists do is
he's not going to really accept it as an actual
defeat. Trump will say, I never really wanted
this anyway. I gave you four years. I made
the country great again. If you want Joe Biden,
I'm going to go. I'm still rich. I'm the best
businessman. I'm going to build buildings
or whatever else the case may be. He's never
going to see it as really a defeat because
he is an extreme narcissist.
But I think anybody thinking Trump's throwing
in the towel or not really going to try to
win. We are going to see over the next four
months a significant significant escalation
in Trump's erratic nature. And, yes, he's
going to try to win and every single one of
us has to vote. Which is why we're going to
talk about polling momentarily. I invite you
to join the discussion on the sub, read it
at David Pakman dot com slash r e d DHT. We
have moderators. You are not going to get
bullied. Or if someone tries to bully you,
we're going to cut that crap out. It's a it's
a place for respectful discussion. And I invite
you to join us.